in India tobacco use is so widespread a
million deaths every year are attributed
to its use tobacco can be stuffed inside
a wide variety of cigarettes and biddies
minced into a masala of spices known as
good guy or piled on top of paan a leafy
addictive stimulant that multiplies a
user's risk of oral cancer almost
tenfold those million deaths a year are
one reason why the Framework Convention
on tobacco control is being held in
Delhi this year run by the World Health
Organization the convention is dedicated
to curbing tobacco use about 15 years
ago the World Health Organization which
is the UN's Public Health arm decided
they wanted to combat tobacco use so
they created a treaty which turned out
to be sort of a a sub agency of the
organization and it's called the
Framework Convention on tobacco control
and every two years this treaty has a
legislative meeting so it's sort of like
a congress of all the people all the
countries who have signed on to the
treaty there are 180 countries who get
together every two years and vote on
issues about tobacco use tobacco
reduction policies and things like that
but who gets a say and what the w-h-o
does is a hotly contested matter only
thirty members of the public and
selected members of the media are
treated to stage-managed press
conferences with no opportunity to ask
tough questions nations with state-owned
tobacco companies are warmly welcomed
but anyone with the slightest connection
to a private tobacco company is shown
the exit with less than 5% of our annual
funding coming from corporations some of
which have an interest in this issue
reason TV was not allowed in the door
but an official lanyard attached to my
hotel room key was all it took to walk
past the security theater and join the
approved media groups
ladies and gentlemen the challenges
faced by again in the area of tobacco
control formerly we continue to take
strong steps for revelation of the
smokeless tobacco products and have
prohibited the production safe
transportation being excluded from the
conference didn't go over well with
India's tobacco farmers after just a few
minutes of protests outside the
convention 500 farmers were corralled by
police and detained inside this local
police station after a brief negotiation
and a bribe offered from an unnamed
source outside of Reason TV leaders of
the movement were temporarily released
to speak with us outside the walls of
the police station we were planning to
have our own meeting we are protesting
to save our livelihoods web CTC process
is going on in a very undemocratic
manner we have been representing to the
government to consider our pleas not to
go excessive on the regulations because
it's our livelihoods at stake but
unfortunately it's not being done as the
farmers were being released from jail
that evening convention delegates voted
to expel the media from the remainder of
the conference
that's when drew Johnson took a stand by
staying seated I got asked to leave I
did not and ultimately a group of a
group of security guards physically
removed me pulled me out of the building
and this is a large ballroom there are
1,500 delegates it was quite a scene as
you can imagine but I thought it was
completely inappropriate that the media
was kicked out because this is
ultimately a taxpayer-funded event of
people making legislation that could
impact the lives of six billion people
90 percent of the people on earth and
there's no
accountability there's no transparency
so when the media were kicked out I
decided the next morning I would go in
and try to do my job as a journalist and
write a story about what was going on
that day do you swear that the testimony
you're about to give is the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth if
it's hard to understand why a four
billion dollar organization like the
w-h-o feels threatened by both
journalists and the average Indian
farmer who lives on about $3 a day it's
worth recalling the source of all that
hostility yes or no do you believe
nicotine is not addictive I believe
nicotine is not addictive yes there was
certainly a lot of mistrust of the
tobacco industry and a lot of it frankly
is the industry's fault for some of the
facts that they hid and and some of the
ways that they the tactics that they use
to try to keep people smoking
congressmen cigarettes and nicotine
clearly do not meet the classic
definitions of addiction there is no
okay shake that isn't knowing but now
we've reached a point where that
hesitancy to engage with the tobacco
industry has also impacted things like
east cigarettes and vaping products and
things that people actually use to stop
smoking
we've written down the number of
Harden's because
as the World Health Organization turns
its attention to regulating the vaping
industry a small but determined
political resistance is forming across
Asia Association of vapers India it's a
fairly new body that we've formed as a
consumer forum to work with the
regulatory framework to help influence
the policymakers to make sure that they
understand how we get information from
the scientists work with them and
present these cases back to the
influences of policymakers also pushing
back is aaron b Bert's a documentary
filmmaker who has set up his own press
conferences in Delhi to counter the
w-h-o narrative and spread the gospel of
vaping the w-h-o is doing this really
shady stuff where they're I mean they're
not inviting the media to be a part of
it they were kicking media out of this
event but they they're inviting people
like China who is the world's largest
tobacco company literally government-run
monopolies into this they're also
allowing people that are bought and paid
for by a big pharmaceutical companies to
come in I mean all these cancer
societies are granted access to witness
the stuff clearly they have a huge
conflict of interest because they take
money from the same pharmaceutical
companies that make nicorette gum and
then lobby against the competitors of
that gum it doesn't make any sense it
makes me very suspicious
it remains to be seen whether a nation
concerned with purity of spirit will be
able to legislate purity of the body
that's the - a great emergency NOLA
already mandatory disclaimers appear in
bollywood movies whenever a character
smokes a cigarette and the state of
Punjab has arrested parvesh Kumar a
salesman of electronic cigarettes
sentencing him to three years of hard
labor the vapor technology has come out
of the box and there's no putting it
back in the real challenge here I think
is to tell the story of what goes on
behind these closed doors which are
well-meaning people for the most part
who are trying to get people to stop
smoking that do the wrong thing right or
wrong it can't be easy getting a hundred
and eighty signatory nations to agree on
much of anything
this year the seventh session of the
Congress of the parties resolved only
two things of note reaffirming their
determination to regulate vaping
products and further limiting access to
the convention by the public due to
potential tobacco industry interference
two resolutions that seemed designed to
elicit more protest from the public at
the next conference two years from now
nobody tells me what to do